foreign
foreign
[Music]
councilors ladies and gentlemen and I
welcome you to this meeting of the
council
as this is our first meeting since the
sad passing of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II I invite you to join with
me in a minutes of silence so that as a
council we can formally pay our respects
foreign
home
thank you
before we formally start this meeting I
would normally invite my chapter in or
one of them to say a few words
unfortunately the Reverend Richard
who's normally would have done this
evening's delivery is
you might have to stand up yet don't
worry
he's unable to join us because his wife
is on well and those of you who may know
him he has two children under the age of
five and he's on Parental Duty so he's
had to step down at the last moment but
I just thought I would share with you
just a very very few words from a prayer
of intercession that was read as part of
the judge's service on Sunday morning in
the cathedral and it followed
immediately upon the the prayer for
those in the legal profession it is very
short
we pray for our Lord mayor Mayors
counselors and officers across greater
Manchester
for those we ask you grant a vision that
our region May flourish and that lives
be changed for good through their work
in our boroughs amen amen
we move two apologies I've received
apologies for absence from counselors
akinola Axford councilor Miss Blackburn
chalkin dagnall Freeman mertzer and
Morgan and councilor Taylor has notified
me she is traveling back from London
hopes to be with us by eight o'clock but
she is also subsequently told me she's
on an earlier train so she'll be here
soon
um Just for information not all
technical facilities are available in
the chamber I'm assured they will be
available for our next meeting and you
might find that some microphones are not
working if that's the case we have
roaming mics on standby should anybody's
not be working
also because some units are not working
votes this evening will be by a show of
hands
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
YouTube channel
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
activity promotes Democratic engagement
in accordance with Section 100a brackets
9 closed brackets of the Local
Government Act
1972. thank you
the first item on the agenda is the
minutes and I move at the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of July 2022 be
taken as read and signed as a correct
record subject to formally recording the
amendment moved in respect to the motion
on save our Rivers at minute 27.
is that seconded second nature thank you
all in favor
item two announcements
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening no
thank you chair thank you leader do the
chairs of the scrutiny committees have
anything to announce on behalf of their
committees councilors Acton
thank you councilor Acton Council of
wetton
thank you thank you Mr Mayor I want you
to announce something from Health
scrutiny that is important to the
council and important beyond the council
to our community but unfortunately it
has lost some of its significance just
in in the last few days
Health scrutiny has looked at the
ongoing closed closed status of the
Altrincham minor injuries unit at the
last two meetings
it's fair to say that the topic exercise
the committee greatly with most members
expressing concerns speaking and
appending thoughtfully and with passion
we were led to believe after the second
meeting that a phased reopening of the
minor injuries unit would commence in
January
a step forward even if it was not a
totally practical offering for the
public
however this plan has been overtaken by
events elsewhere and now stands to be
delayed somewhat further whilst more
review work is undertaken
so then my announcement Mr Mayor is
reduced to this
the health scrutiny committee is very
concerned about the continued closure of
the minor injuries unit
it sees that the message that this is
sending out to the community creates
concerns as to the ongoing wider use of
the alteringham General Hospital site
we have called for the NHS to reopen the
minor injuries unit as speedily as
possible
and give clear signals clear unambiguous
signals that the rest of the hospital's
uses are there to stay Thank you Mr
Mayor
thank you councilor wetton
um councilor Denise Weston do you have
anything scrutiny thank you thank you
Isom 3 questions
members have submitted five questions
for this meeting which have been listed
on the council website for members of
the public to view each questioner has
the right of a supplementary question
and all shall be put and answered
without discussion we will now take the
questions in the order in which they
were received
the first question please is from
counselor G
instrument
would you care to read your question
counselors can executive members for
environmental services please provide me
with an update on the common position
with a recruitment and temporary
backfeeding of roles for the bin Crews
would councilor ad said the executive
member like to respond please
thank you uh there and for your question
come from Z
the waste service is a
requires between 106 and 111 staff
depending on seasonal requirements
levels of holidays and other absences
the service currently employs 99
full-time equivalent and in addition to
this has 13 regular temporary staff
supplied by a recruitment agency the
service therefore has seven full-time
vacancies and he tends to move suitable
staff from temporary to permanent
contracts 12 weeks to permanent contract
12 weeks employment
foreign
do you have a supplementary question yes
uh thank you for your response as an
elected member I'm proud to be the first
British Chinese speaker in this chamber
Bowden is a lovely place to live with
beautiful Parks outstanding schools and
a fantastic community that we are all
proud of since being elected in May I
have received numerous complaints from
border residents regarding Mr Bean
collection's blocked drains and the lack
of collection Services I knew that other
members are receiving complaints too
recently I had a digital surgery session
with Australian grammar school counselor
Z would you care to put your question
please rather than just tell us what's
new members tell me that what additional
actions are planned to take place to
guide the services up to the level that
Boden and other Russians expect and
Reserve
sorry councilor I'd say would you care
to respond to the supplementary question
thank you mayor and for your
supplementary question Council yeah uh
obviously waste is one of the issues
we've been discussing on a very regular
basis at all my meetings and it's
something we've been pushing Amy on
quite heavily and indeed over the past
couple of years two three years since we
took control that they we have been
implementing performance penalties for
any poor service we can't say that uh
since Luke's been organized we now can
see a more steady state of actually
across the ball and what this looks like
and predominantly all the rounds are now
generally even but there has been on
Mondays tend to have heavier loads
therefore if we have a recruitment
therefore we have staff absences on a
Monday like has happened on occasions
this ends as a knock-on effect to the
following Monday where sometimes they
cannot always complete the rounds so I
can say Obviously during the Spring this
problem went away it occurred during the
summer and now it has leveled off again
however we're concerned that this could
at some point potentially rise again so
we are looking at potentially options
around how to improve them on these
services and an action plan has been put
together working alongside Amy and a
report will be coming to Future
executive actually how we can implement
this to actually make sure we spread the
working more well it is even but
although it will potentially be more
uneven it'll actually should give better
capacity on Mondays which seems to be
the problem thank you
thank you councilor ad said question two
is another question from councilor G
can exaction members for finance and the
governors outline the uh what future
plans the council has to support travel
residents with the cost of living
thank you councilor Zee as the executive
member councilor Ross please could you
respond
thank you mayor um in order to save time
I did provide counselor she with a
written response earlier today I'm just
checking have you received it and are
you happy to go to a supplementary on
that basis yeah I uh I receive it and
that keep it
right bearing in mind the fact you've
received a written response from
councilor Ross already would you now
please put your supplementary question
thank you
and financial strategy
2023-24 to
2024-25 approved an increase of 3.99 in
console tax and that is before fire and
the police precepts are added onto the
residence council tax bill that's the
executive member believe that such a
young cruise is a fair on residents when
many are already struggling to pay their
bills
thank you culture Z councilor Ross would
you care to respond
sler G4 that supplementary question
um you will note that because of
austerity over the past 12 Years a
situation for local authorities has
become quite chronic when it comes to
funding so each year it budgets we have
to balance out this provision of
services with savings and income
proposals as well as the council tax
level
um this proposal will bring in much
needed Revenue to promote our Frontline
Services ideally we'd have a government
that provided more
Central grants to us and reverse the
spending cuts that have taken place over
the past 12 years we are not in that
situation and indeed mayor we Face a
situation where despite what the Prime
Minister said at Prime Minister's
questions today we are facing another
bout of austerity coming up where we
will be looking at an even more perilous
state for local Authority Finance across
the country so yes of course we we we
never take lightly what we do with
council tax increases and we will be
going through that process again with
this budget but what I suggest
counselors as you are still a member of
the conservative party I would encourage
you to Lobby your own ministers to get
some clarity actually govern would be a
start and get some and get some money to
local government from Central funding
because across the country councils are
suffering under the weight of 12 Years
of austerity and need help so that we
can produce and provide the Frontline
Services people oh dear so if you can
take that that's the Prime Minister and
the the cabinet that are in place I'm
sure the whole of the council will
appreciate any lobbying you are able to
do on our behalf
thank you councilor Ross for your
response to the supplementary question
we moved to question three which is from
councilor fresh please
thank you Miss mayor in February this
year Trafford provided a freedom of
information request answer about the
number of hike Vision CCTV units that's
just introduction I'm sorry to interrupt
you just I I've been looking through
um the Constitution and and it does
clearly state in the Constitution that
there is an expectation that when any
member is speaking in the chamber they
should stand I'm sorry to maybe
embarrass you but not at all that is if
you if you look in the Constitution it
is there and you know I hope you take it
in the spirit in which it's meant thank
you thank you Mr Mayor not at all
forgive me if I sneeze Midway through
page 13 of the report attached to that
reply lists more than 90 hike Vision
units in use across the borough hike
Vision was blacklisted by the American
government in 2019 over concerns about
their role in human rights violations
targeting the uyghurs in xinjiang
province of China the House of Commons
has since said that human rights
violations in xinjiang amount to Suicide
genocide hike Vision have Chinese
Communist Party government tenders to
establish facial recognition cameras at
the entrances to places of worship and
indeed to the re-education camps where
uyghurs are detained
as a result a report from the Foreign
Affairs select committee last year
recommended that the government forbids
hike Vision equipment from operating in
this country so my question is can the
executive tell us whether there are any
units that were installed after that
date and indeed if we have some plans to
perhaps remove them thank you thank you
for your question councilor Wright as
the executive member responsible for
Community safety would you care to
respond please uh yeah thank you mayor
and thank you councilor for us for your
question in answers to your first
question the answer is no cameras have
not been installed after that particular
date in answer to your more wide
question a substantial review of the
council CCTV policy has been undertaken
and a revised policy will be published
shortly as part of that review a
substantial audit of traffic Council
CCTV systems is being undertaken
traffic Council does not possess any
form of biometric recognition software
which was the issue that caused
particularly concern around the cameras
there would be a considerable Capital
expense of remusing and removing and
replacing the existing cameras without
significant benefits of presence and
just to give you an idea of the cost of
that the cost of a new camera of similar
specifications 600 pounds plus the cost
of taking the old one down and putting a
new one up plus all the cost of
reconnection higher of cherry pickers
and road closures and as you'll be aware
by our budget monitoring in my colleague
councilor Ross we currently have no
funding for that as things stand thank
you
thank you councilor right Council of
fresh do you have a supplementary
question
thank you mayor yes briefly it is
reassuring that Trafford obviously
hasn't installed any of these uh more
recently and procurement is normally a
matter for Council departments not a
political decision day-to-day but I
wonder if the executive member might
agree with me that the report by the
Foreign Affairs select committee
recommending they be banned in the UK
provides evidence that we can
demonstrate misconduct and therefore it
would be right that the council could
amend that procurement policy going
forwards that we could strike hike
Vision off the list which is what the
liberal Democrats are calling for this
evening
sorry counselor right yes go ahead thank
you thank you mayor and thank you
Council for us yes so um we we have a
contract with a company called security
Dynamics until 2024
um who currently Supply our our um CCTV
cameras we will obviously go out to
Tender based on the procurement laws at
the time following 2024 however I uh can
categorically say that we'll be not
purchasing those types of equipment
going forward thank you councilor
thank you councilor Wright uh question
four is from councilor Coggins your
question please
thank you mayor can the meeting please
have an update on the council's plans
for a Citizens assembly on the climate
crisis
colgan's councilor Williams as the
executive member for climate change
please could you respond
thank you chair and thank you Council
Coggins for your question and the
concept of holding a Citizens assembly
on the subject of climate change was
developed at a time when public
awareness of the topic was still
evolving and miss being overtaken by
other concerns since then the extreme
weather events notably the record
temperatures experienced this summer and
the appalling floods recently observed
in Pakistan have placed the climate
crisis once again at the center of the
public agenda
similarly the growing cost of living
crisis an unprecedented rise in energy
costs sparked by domestic and Global
events have made Energy Efficiency and
consumption a daily topic of
conversation we all think differently
about where our energy comes from and
how we use it with this in mind it is
clear that time has moved on and in the
context of ongoing austerity and demands
on Council finances it is right to
review the intention to hold a Citizens
assembly our finite resources need to be
directed to activities that can most
effectively contribute toward tackling
the climate crisis
for those reasons the executive is
determined not to proceed with the
citizens assembly at this time but to
devote more effort into tangible
measures toward combating the climate
crisis thank you chair
thank you councilor Williams councilor
Coggins do you have a supplementary
question
uh thank you Council councilor Williams
um yes I agree there has been some
increase in public awareness um
uh part of that I guess is updating the
council's website which I know at the
start of this meeting still said that
assistance assembly will take place in
March 2022. I wonder
we can't at this point say that the
council has finished with engaging the
public on this so what plans do we have
to actually announce and update the
website to say that this will not be
happening and alternative ways to
continue to engage the public on this
thank you
thank you councilor Coggins councilor
William should you care to respond
thank you chairman thank you Council
supplementary question you'll be pleased
to hear that um this evening just before
this meeting I have emailed the
corporate director place about um
amending the website so it's got more
up-to-date material in terms of engaging
the public I I think that's an
absolutely key aspect of this work and
I'd like to think that we can continue
to pursue that by the councils what not
the councils via the multi-agency
multi-partnership climate commission
which I know that you're an active
member on Council and I'm very much
welcome your continued participation in
that process thank you
you councilor Williams uh councilor Miss
Blackburn submitted the final question
but has since tested positive so I
invite one of her colleagues to place
the question on her behalf is that
possible
or shall I read the question which was
published on the website anyway
I'll read the question for all concerned
councilor Miss Blackburn's question was
will the executive member let me know
how many section 106 monies have been
used over the last two years to provide
disabled appropriate equipment in our
boroughs parks and the answer hopefully
will come from councilor ad said as exec
member for Environmental Services
I've got problems to find a balance
sitting down and trying to well trying
to stand up and read this because my
screen microphone's in the middle of the
screen so apologies if I had to sit down
to try and read it
response is section 106 monies are
currently reviewed to identify where
play equipment is identified as part of
the agreement
this particular funding often has
specific requirements and is linked to
specific areas set out in the section
106 agreement but also some agreements
allow flexibility and use these funds
these particular funds have not been
utilized for any play equipment during
the previous two years however
replacement of play equipment is
identified as an area that needs funding
hence the council's capital program is
being used for that purpose
when carving out play equipment
refurbishment the chemical's own Green
Space Capital program for play areas has
been allocated for this type of work and
has been focused on replacing all the
equipment with more inclusive play
equipment
in
2021-22 the Green Space Capital program
allocation was 127 000. to play areas in
22-23
the figure is from 226
000 pound areas from the above
allocations multi-play areas at Walnut
Park Newton Park and kensal Street areas
are in the process of being replaced
with inclusive play units with an
estimated cost of seventy thousand
pounds we also we are also installing
other inclusive equipment including
communication boards and signage to
assist users with disabilities such as
autism
thank you councilor ad said and although
there's no supplementary question I
think in your response to the first
question you've probably answered what
that supplementary question might have
been thank you so we move on to item
four membership of committees listed on
the summons is a change of substitute on
the Planning Development management
committee which is being reported to the
council for information can this be
noted please
thank you item five petition road safety
and traffic Management South Downs Road
item 4 is a petition receiving
517 signatures to create a 20 miles per
hour Zone around South Downs Road and
also request visible signage traffic
calming measures and wider Pathways in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme organizers of the petition are
allowed to speak to the petition for
five minutes and we have Bridget green
with us this evening a local resident
who will introduce the petition
following their introduction the
petition will be debated by Council for
a maximum of 15 minutes as is the agreed
practice for petitions at council
speeches are normally limited to one
member from each of the groups and since
there is only 15 minutes allowed for the
debate each group will be allocated 3
minutes and 45 seconds following the
debate the leader of the council will
then summarize the council's response if
Council sense to these Arrangements I
will now invite Bridget green to
introduce the petition are we in
agreement with those arrangements
thank you
so
um Bridget green would you oh
ready on the my right hand side your
left thank you
foreign
offers some assistance to ensure that
the
microphone
is working appropriately so all members
can hear what Bridget is saying
yes and I will certainly allow her to
start again
well
I think we're
I think we have a plan B arriving here
so much better idea
okay I'll start again sorry
um so South Downs Road it's a key access
route to Bowden schools and it's also an
important route that links Bowden to the
south of Hale
this petition asked the council to
improve the safety of this route for
people on foot and people on bikes
whether that's a parent walking young
children to Bowdoin church school on
Grange Road a teenager riding a bike to
alteringham grammar school for boys on
Marlborough Road or a resident walking
between villages
we ask that you do this by enforcing a
mandatory 20 mile per hour speed limit
install visible signs and widen
Pavements where possible and change the
road layout to get drivers to slow down
one such pinch Point already exists
towards the top of this road
local drivers are often very careful
when using the road particularly in the
narrow bendy sections it nears hail here
the road is not very wide for cars and
the pavement is at points no more than
two foot wide
so if a parent and child are on the
pavement they will fill the entire
pavement with the driver will need to
slow right down as they can't take more
Road space in case a car or van is
coming the other way
not all drivers however are that slow or
careful it's not uncommon to have an SUV
partially over the white line in the
middle of the road as it comes around a
bend and cyclists are often overtaken on
a corner
I myself had an unpleasant experience
walking back to Bowdoin recently I was
approaching a bend on a narrow bit of
pavement when a light Goods vehicle came
around the corner too fast and its rear
wheel mounted the curb so I was on a two
foot wide which is what that stretch of
pavement I had a stone wall on my right
and suddenly I've got this Fat Tire in
my on my pavement as well it was really
scary I had to flatten myself to the
wall
some push chairs struggle with an arrow
pavement especially if there's a child
walking beside the push chair
older children and parents with young
children should be able to walk to
school
people who choose to walk have a right
to Safe walking routes
this road is dangerous and frankly I can
understand why a parent would actually
choose to drive their child to school as
a safer option
but we also have a major problem with
congestion in this area at school
drop-off and pickup times as a resident
on Grange Road I can be stuck in
stationary traffic for 10 minutes if I
arrive home at 3 pm
there is standing traffic on South dams
waiting to turn left into Grange Road
and worse still I've seen traffic queued
on the main road
waiting to turn right into South Downs
and then into Grange Road
Grange Road itself is narrow at points
and I've seen cars drive over the
pavement numerous times
to bypass standing traffic that's
blocking the road I've seen a car that's
turning left from the main road into
South Downs Road drive on the pavement
completely that's whole car on the
pavement just to avoid standing traffic
children who do walk to school have to
breathe in the fumes from the standing
traffic and it does smell
the only way to solve this congestion is
to encourage more children to walk and
ride their bikes to school and of course
they need safe routes to be able to do
that more active travel gives us less
congestion and happier local residents
less air pollution and healthier
children
one of trafford's traffic council's
performance indicators is addressing our
climate crisis by reducing CO2 emissions
and one way of helping this will be by
enabling people to leave their cars at
home and make more Journeys by foot and
by bike
for Success our road routes need to be
more suited to pedestrians and cyclists
and the South Downs route to Bowdoin
schools could be made a good example of
this reducing the number of cars on our
roads at the start and end of the school
day makes it better for parents who do
have to drive their children to school
better for children that walk school and
better for local people that live there
I don't think I'm telling you anything
that you don't already know and
sometimes there seems to be a lack of
concrete action to match the words and
your plans and do appreciate that
funding is extremely tight but please
can we find some creative ways to make
this happen
thank you for listening
and thank you Bridget and thank you for
your time making your presentation this
evening
Council I'd said as the executive member
for environmental and Regulatory service
I invite you now to respond on behalf of
the labor group
thank you man thank you to Bridget for
bringing the petition tonight we always
welcome some petitions and uh and I
always enjoy discussing things like road
safety and and work around schools I
actually uh set up a special committee
where it looks at all aspects of safety
around schools and that encompasses a
number of areas schools particularly I
know isn't just a problem in your area
I'm not sure you know it's a problem
across the whole mother so we have been
looking at some trial schemes of school
streets and we've got one scheme up and
running we're funding through the mass
challenge fund and an obviously online
shortly there's also some special
funding from tfgm to do similar a number
of areas across the borough and and
they're actually in training I'm the
institutes overcoming periods so we are
looking at that I accept that schools is
a big problem and as well as school
streets role safety department also
offer a range of other schemes such as
what once a week and other stuff there
are schools in there you might want to
talk to schools and see if they partake
in these where they give little rewards
for children who walk to school and they
can and it can become quite interesting
where the kids actually encouraging
their parents to walk them so they can
get the rewards there are also many
other aspects of things they can do
which are walking buses and the whole
range of things too smooth to the area
and they're actually looking at some
other new road safety initiatives over
the coming uh period of two transport of
the way to Manchester that that will
open to be able to I can't see where I
can move old out yet because the details
haven't been confirmed up yet but tfgm
will actually raise it with our local
Road Safety officers we're actually
looking at this extensively so schools
is a big issue when we take that very
seriously I'm looking at that just in
general terms except that many roads
across the world our problems are quite
old and we have a whole range of
problems now I don't know a specific
problem of every Road in all parts of
the world but our team will once it will
now be passed over to the Royal safety
and they'll actually investigate it and
they'll look at all the options for it
like an option to play as well to see
what the problem is 20 zones sometimes
help sometimes they do not solve the
problems there and certainly some of the
things you mentioned there would not
necessarily be resolved by 20 Zone
sometimes a local environment can do
more I think you've mentioned like where
it's very we know that itself is
conducive to reducing speed it was Heavy
wide and there's plenty of space cars
who tend to speed Vehicles tend to speed
where it's very narrow that there's
tendency to actually for the vehicle
slow down as you've highlighted
potentially perhaps some commercial
vehicles do not fall always fall the
same thing so whereas if you've got your
own vehicle you're either in mindful of
Road humps so if you care about it it's
just damaging the suspension it can
damage other parts of the car but
however those things don't seem to apply
to some commercial vehicles
unfortunately so that's why 20 zones
work really well I live in one and it
worked it can work but it doesn't
necessarily help solve all the problems
that happen that's why we need that
investigation to actually look into the
needs of any one particular area now we
do have some schemes that we're going to
be looking at trialling uh some of the
20 zones as you know along under
previous government that 20 zones was a
priority and we had managed to do huge
wide areas of schemes like there is uh I
live in and so forth but unfortunately
that funding stopped in 2010 and that
huge amounts of funding is no longer
available so we are looking we are doing
some potentially try and do our best
with some smaller schemes where the
funding is much limited and and they
have been in process now been
implemented and we are continuing to
look at ways which can fund those
because it's something that is my heart
and my colleagues I'm sure all parties
across the chamber would fully support
that and we'll look at innovative ways
of actually doing that and I want to
continue to push the transport for
greater Manchester and actually
encouraging things like sequence on
because for me they are Paramount to get
enroll served in our local areas thank
you
thank you councilor ad said is there a
speaker to this petition on behalf of
the conservative group
thank you Mr bear and uh can I also say
Well done to Bridger green for
organizing the petition and speaking
here tonight I recently met with the
police Amy and Bowden church school
actually very close to this location
that we're talking about and at that
meeting we set out some extra safety
measures for that school in particular
the essence of the problem faced in this
location is actually faced in many other
parts of Bowden and indeed across
Trafford it's a sign of our times
it is the balancing of the safety of
children different aspects of their
safety not just Road Safety but the
whole range of concerns that parents
live with daily
and often these prompt the use of the
car hence the motorcades the delivering
collecting the door-to-door
it will take a great deal to alter that
parental mindset
and it will take reassurance at a higher
level than just Road Safety in my view
pressures of today's society jobs other
care demands running a home
people have demanding schedules making
cars a frequently used option of their
lives
to the specifics of the petition well in
Bowden we're currently Consulting across
the ward on similar measures but more
widely spread
petition tonight though also seeks
changes to Street Scene infrastructure
and that I fear May Place some of the
objectives too far out of reach
and that is not a dead hand from me just
a realistic observation about costs
we've already heard some comments about
Council finances tonight
and so I think it is one that is more
for the council's leadership than it is
for me
going forward I fear that less and less
nice to haves will be deliverable
the 20 mile an hour concept has its
detractors many are cynical about it it
has its limitations in law but it is
certainly seen as a reminder it's a
prompt it draws drivers Minds to the
circumstances in the immediate area
in many of those areas the speed limit
is actually created by the smaller size
of the roads in residential areas and
the volume of vehicles themselves and
that speed limit is well below 20 miles
an hour
however 20 mile an hour signage is a key
to raising awareness of the need for a
heightened attention to driving
it is a very visible alert to
responsible drivers
so with those words
somewhat qualified support but support I
awake with interest the reflections of
the leader of the council thank you very
much
thank you councilor wetton do we also
have a speaker to respond on behalf of
the liberal Democrat group
yes speaking on a different microphone
okay so thank you mayor firstly
um heartfelt thanks to Bridget green and
to the 517 residents around the South
Downs Road Langham Road Grange Road and
Marlborough Road areas who have worked
hard to bring this petition this evening
to full Council to create a 20 more
miles per hour Zone in that area
and thank you for bringing this to
traffic Council it's much appreciated
so this petition it clearly shows the
strength of feeling amongst our
residents for another 20 miles per hour
Zone
because it's on our full Council agenda
tonight having only had a similar motion
and a different area at the last four
Council
and at that last fall Council it was
mentioned by our group leader councilor
new gross that a reminder that it was in
2012 a decade ago before many of the
councilors here were elected it was the
liberal Democrat group who first
introduced emotion on 24 mile per hour
zones and this was supported by labor
but at the time it was rejected by the
ruling conservative group and hearing
the group tonight I fear there is still
some lukewarmness towards
um 20 mile per hour zones from from that
conservative group so we then brought in
a
so lukewarmness okay so the labor group
did then bring a second motion on 20
mile per hour zones which of course
supported by the liberal Democrats but I
just remind full Council that it was
agreed by our as far back as July 2013
that a list of residential roads will be
drawn up
near schools which would benefit from 20
mile per hour speed limits
and in 2020 probably within the memory
of everybody here we then agreed a
further motion to lower speeds and build
safer roads
and just moving on from that the current
default speed in most areas is still 30
miles per hour
but research shows that half of drivers
do admit to regularly driving above that
limit
being struck by a car at 35 miles an
hour means only a shocking 50 chance of
survival
at 30 miles per hour there's still only
a 55 chance of survival
this affects not just those directly
involved but also creates a wider fear
of traffic for us and for our children
yet at 20 miles per hour the survival
rate jumps to about 97 percent
so this petition requests more visible
appropriate signage to warn drivers
traffic calming measures and wider
pathways
it's also key a key route to school for
many many pupils
few people walk or cycle on this road as
a pavement's too narrow as the petition
outlines for push chairs and speeding
traffic and it's too busy
mostly to cycle along safely
a 20-part power limit would certainly
create safety for our children and it
will benefit the whole community
and in the petition a 20 mile per hour
limit in this area would also allevate
other problems for instance parking
issues congestion and standing traffic
as more pupils would then be able to get
to school by either walking or biking
it's Trafford we can improve race safety
create smoother traffic flow and
increase pedestrian safety by having
more 20 mile per hour speed limits areas
a special near to our children's schools
many examples from other areas show how
this can be done
not only do we get enhanced Road Safety
can you start to wrap up counselors but
also improvements in air quality a
reduction in carbon emissions from Fuel
and lower bills for repairs for cars
and we mustn't go without mentioning
healthier Lifestyles with more walking
and cycling too so finally wrapping up I
would like to conclude by offering the
wholehearted support of the Bringers of
this motion to Bridget green and all
those that signed it it has the full
support of the liberal Democrat group
thank you thank you councilor Brophy and
now could we move to hopefully a speaker
from the green party thank you councilor
Coggins
okay it's councilor Leicester thank you
mayor and and firstly I'd like to say
thank you to Bridget for bringing the
petition to the council today
um I think the fact that it gained more
than 500 signatures actually over the
course of just a few days really
highlights the public concern for road
safety generally and specifically the
the issues of South down Road South
sorry South Downs Road
South Downs Road could be a major
walking route between the south of Hale
and the primary and secondary schools in
Bowden however it isn't because people
are too frightened to walk along it due
to the speed of the cars and the narrow
Pavements instead they get into the cars
and they drive their children to school
which adds to the problem why would
people want to risk walking with their
children when it involves their
children's head being just inches from
the wing mirrors of vehicles are going
at 30 miles an hour and more
so as the local as a local councilor for
Hail Central it's a regular topic of
conversation on the doorstep and with
people who contact me
the presence of hgvs on the road is also
an issue and the head teachers at the
schools have supported the need to
address this problem
it's an issue that people have tried to
address before one outcome of the was
the provision of a Crossing Patrol well
welcome this doesn't doesn't address the
issue of speeding cars especially on the
bends with narrow Pavements
in 2020 it was deemed that nothing could
be done and the process of creating a 20
mile an hour limit was too difficult and
costly however times have moved on the
greater Manchester B Network commits to
prioritizing connecting up routes and
making it safer to travel on on foot or
by bike for everyday trips in particular
on school routes
the trapezoan design plan has set the
objective of encouraging sustainable
movement and connected neighborhoods and
visaging an emphasis on linking
movements in place prioritizing cycle
and pedestrian movement and reducing the
Reliance on the car this supports the
green party position that we should have
a default 20 mile an hour limit on all
residential roads across Trafford
a commitment was made back in 2020 also
to put not suitable for hgv signs but
they actually haven't happened
the road was also Declassified which in
theory may have resulted in less traffic
as it would no longer be a recommended
route for sat navs unfortunately Google
and the other certain navs haven't
caught up so although although the
classification changed the significant
time ago I have followed this question
up the question of mapping up with
officers who are going to look into it
with all of this in mind the green group
would support this petition and ask that
road safety on South Downs would would
be reviewed and as a counselor that
reckoned that represents the area where
the majority of the road lies I'd
welcome the opportunity to meet officers
from the highways department on South
Downs Road and to re-look at the
situation bearing in mind the public
appetite to make things better and the
fact that we should be prioritizing
school routes okay
thank you councilor Leicester uh finally
will the leader of the council summarize
what will now happen with the petition
thank you
thank you chair and thank you very much
to Bridget for bringing the petition I
don't think for a moment that this is an
unreasonable request indeed it's a
location that I know very well as an
alumni of one of the schools that
Bridget mentioned in Her speech what I
would say though is that the council has
limited funding for the implementation
of 20 mile per hour zones so this will
be assessed alongside all of the other
requests that we've received and a
decision will be taken on a on the basis
of need as determined by our engineering
Specialists so at this point it's too
early to say definitively either way
whether or not we will be able to
implement this request what I would say
is as as I already have that I think
that this is a location that that is
problematic for a number of different
reasons but I also acknowledge the point
made by councilor wetton not only about
the financial constraints that the
council finds itself in but the
particular geographical constraints that
this location that could add
significantly to the cost stretching
what is quite a limited budget so we
will take it away thank you very much
not just to Bridget but to everybody who
signed the petition and we will work
through with our team where this is
assessed
um well set against all of the other
requests we've received and if budget
allows then we will take this forward
thank you chair
thank you leader thank you once again
Bridget for joining us to make your
presentation
we moved to items six publication of
members addresses on the Declaration of
Interest register item six the
recommendation from standards committee
concerning the inclusion of members
addresses on Declaration forms published
on the website I invite the standards
chair councilor Kevin Proctor to
introduce and remove the recommendation
councilor Proctor
uh thank you Matt
um it's the report is quite self-evident
really it went to standards committee on
the 22nd of September and we considered
the three potential options for moving
forward on this
um which were to retain the the present
system to make it a make counselors
aware that their interests could be
considered as sensitive and then be
included and the third option which was
to apply a blanket policy where in where
all councilors names wouldn't appear on
on that that register there was some
discussion out at the the standards
committee and it was the anonymous
announcement a decision made that we
should go forward with the blanket
policy which we're asking the council to
approve tonight thank you
thank you councilor Proctor is that
seconded please
secretary said the right to speak thank
you
thank you can I just seek clarification
on this myself
The Proposal is that the register of
interests
does not include
an address of land or property in which
councilors have an interest is that
correct
no this is just a councilor's own
address personal address
right
so who would wish to speak to this
proposal
other than what has already been said
we've got Council of bunting councilor
Holden and the others
no right in which case I think Council
councilor bunting's hand was first up
thank you councilor bunt thank you Mr
Mayor M who else I accept that some
councilors may have his concern many
others may not
um whilst the council wishes to impose a
blanket uh condition across all
councilors in the absence of any other
request would it not be reasonable for a
counselor to opt out should he or she
wish to do so for example I would not
wish to hide my address my address has
been on the website since I was first
elected I am more than happy for it to
remain and I would request that
counselors should be asked
if you wish to have your address moved
it's removed if you wish it to remain it
should remain I don't see why it should
be imposed upon me thank you Mr Mayor
thank you councilor bunting councilor
Holden
thank you Mr Smith
strangely my colleague and I and Saint
Mary's Ward have not spoken about this
but we appear to have come to exactly
the same opinion
I personally am much more afraid of God
at my advantage than I have of someone
knocking on my door and being insulting
um I've been threatened or put in
positions of threat for most of my adult
life
and they've never come to anything one
because I've never been that important
but two they always end the same way
and whether that's in a bar in Belfast
or a Leipzig gasthof
you're drinking with your enemy
and everybody forgets it
so I can't take the some of the
arguments in the report really very
seriously because I don't believe I'm
important enough and I would really
welcome the ability to be able to
publish my address
on any document you like so that any
decision that I support any policy I put
forward my residents can see how it
might affect me
so I just want to stress the fact that
there's not that much to be afraid of
there may be in some very special cases
and in those cases fine
have a voluntary process whereby the
names and addresses are not held but for
the vast majority of us let's advertise
to our residents where we live
thank you
thank you councilor Holden well those
are the two councilors of councilor
minis now wishes to say something thank
you
I just say a whole
here I mean it's not a secret where I
live
um my whole Ward knows where I live
pretty much and they know where Jane
lives and you know and they know where
will is I don't
I think if we want to opt out fine
because I think yeah everyone should
have a choice but I just think that you
know you can choose either way it was to
say that nobody's address should be
published I think it's up to the
individual surely
thank you thank you councilor minis
councilor Carter
plus cases
cases and I personally have had some
very distressing experiences and I know
I'm not alone and I have long held that
I wouldn't want my address in the public
domain went through quite a long time
where my husband worked away and I was
by myself with my children and
at the time people did know where I
lived and it was very very frightening
and
um I just feel
um we also have a colleague who hasn't
stood for the council because she is a
Foster carer and she didn't want her
address in the public domain and I think
the work that standards committee have
done on this has been absolutely
brilliant and I would like to support it
every step of the way thank you
sorry we've now got three more hands
there's councilor Coggins there's a one
that's gone down thank you councilor
Thomas and councilor
I got a wonky plan here right we'll take
them in the order of one two three
counselor Coggins let's hear what you
have to say thank you
I said I've been two meetings of the LGA
women's group where I've heard really
quite horrifying stories of the abuse
and recognition
but sorry late moment the horrific
stories I have heard of
um women
um often women who aren't white and who
are counselors
um and if we're going to have a system
where people opt in then I think there
is the danger that as um
cancer Holden uh alluded to actually
people who've opted out might then look
suspicious if if if the idea is that you
can speak freely about things that are
going on across the road from you and
everyone knows you live across the road
from there that those who have opted
into protecting their private lives
their family their foster children their
business whatever it might be if it's
run from home
um are looked on with suspicion so I do
think that it's really important that we
have this option and actually the um
equality that has got to be a system
that protects the most vulnerable so
putting the system a blanket system that
makes the most vulnerable people
um obvious that they are being as
transparent as they can be and protects
them has to be the way to go thank you
thank you councilor Coggins uh
look at it really
councilor Thomas sorry
thank you Matt just be briefly and
follow up whilst it may be okay and I
have no real issue with my address being
published my wife does
and when I first was elected she was a
little bit taken aback that it would be
so I'm fully supportive of the report
that's come through thank you and
councilor Taylor
thank you Matt uh just to say
wholeheartedly disagree with the points
raised by councilor Holden and
councilman s and um wholeheartedly agree
with my female colleagues in the room
here I think we needed to be afforded
that privacy I don't see that having our
address is published is anyway a barrier
to being an effective counselor in all
my other professional roles I'm a public
servant through and through and my
address is not at the disposal of those
other people whether they be patients
those who I educate or residents that I
serve and I wholeheartedly agree that
there is absolutely no need and in fact
it can be dangerous I indeed have
received unsolicited calls from members
of the public to my home without my
knowledge and I think I wholly agree and
congratulate the work that's the
standards committee has done thank you
mayor thank you councilor Taylor thank
you councilor Hartley
I mean I agree with councilor councilor
Taylor I'd just say that I don't I don't
think it's for councilor Holden or
counselor menace to say that people
don't have anything to worry about here
that might be your experience but the
standards committee have done this work
we've heard from other speakers who've
said this is a concern my house was was
criminally damaged the day after I was
elected could be a coincidence but I
suspect it wasn't and I suppose I'd
highlight section two in the report that
this is something that's favored by the
committee of standards in public life
and their mission is to enhance public
partition participation in public life
and
if you're if you're standing or you're
considering standing for election you
want the assurance that you don't have
to worry about your own safety and you
get that by a blanket policy that that
your home address where you live doesn't
have to be published and I think why
should people be deterred from doing
that because as counselor Coggins says
they don't want to be the odd one out so
I really fail to see what the what the
problem is with this I think there's
very good reasons for counselor's
personal addresses not to be published
and uh yeah wholeheartedly support the
report recommendation thank you right I
think councilors we've heard quite a lot
from Members perhaps that the leader
would you like to sum up in your
seconding of the uh adopting the report
thank you leader thank you chair I think
I think the first point to make here
unsurprisedly speaking in favor of the
standards committee recommendation is
that nobody will be failing to submit
the details of properties that they own
to this Council simply that information
will be said for the safety of members
it's very important from a transparency
perspective that we place that on the
record and I am saddened that members
come into this place and suggest that
they can't take these claims seriously
councilor Holden is quite correct that
we may not be particularly famous and
we're certainly not as famous as some
members of parliament but in the week
that we are remembering the murder of a
member of parliament one year ago in
this country I am disappointed by the
comments that we've received and I would
just say chair to give some my idea of
the pitfalls involved in doing this job
that I have had a number of incidents
both out and about in the community
which I accept that this would not
prevent but also at my home and also
with people making very detailed videos
of exactly what they would like to do to
me making get clear that they know my
address and then when I have to have a
marker put on my property and my
mother's property as a result
I find out the list of criminal activity
previously undertaken by that individual
that individual who can find out where I
or any one of us live at any point this
is not about pinning your shoulders back
and saying I'm hard enough I'm not
worried about this this is about saying
collectively we want to be safe in our
roles we know that an attack on one of
us is an attack on all of us and we know
by collectively
withholding that information none of us
can be accused of some sort of as
counselor Coggins said attempt to
conceal where we live we're saying that
is normal for our safety it would not as
councilor Taylor said happen in any
other aspect of public service it should
not happen in this Council and chair I
can see absolutely no reason why all
members would not support the standards
committee proposal thank you
thank you leader for that summary the
report has been moved and seconded can
it be agreed please
thank you on that and thank you leader
for clarifying to me the matter of the
fact that properties whether owned land
rented whatever will be notified to the
council but will be redacted from a
declaration of interest because clearly
the council should know internally what
interests all the interests that members
have in terms of the propriety of their
actions as members but thank you for
that explanation leader
item seven treasury management annual
performance
2021-22 report is a report the exec
member for finance and governance
presented in the 2122 treasury
management annual performance report
presented to council for information
following consideration by both the
accounts and audit committee and the
executive please can the executive
member introduce the report councilor
Ross please thank you thank you mayor as
you say mayor this report was
recommended to the executive and the
council by the accounts and audit
committee back in July the executive
noted the paper back in July this
particular paper looks at the
performance of the year
2021-22 and as usual it looks at the
economic backdrop both financially and
economically there things have moved on
quite considerably since that time but
for the purposes of today I'll focus on
the outside term position as at the end
of March this year there was a net
overspent of 927 000 the key variance
being the level of income received from
the Manchester Airport Holdings there's
in terms of the loan for the car park
or like however what I can say is that
all legislative and regulatory
requirements including or treasury
management Prudential indicators have
been complied with and as ever put on
thanks to my record for a record my
thanks even to the team at treasury
management who assiduously manage our
finances on a day-to-day basis thank you
Matt
thank you councilor Ross the report is
for information is that seconded please
secondly
thank you leader
do any members wish to speak on this
report
I see no hands so can this information
report be noted by Council please
thank you
we move on to motions of which there are
four and have been listed on the summons
in the order in which they received may
I remind members that to get through the
business and to give everyone who wants
to an opportunity to speak it may be
necessary to limit the time for speeches
therefore please can everyone keep their
comments concise and to the point and to
avoid repetition of points already being
made thank you and would I also add that
whilst we are have to finish by 9 30 we
can finish earlier than that if you so
wish
right motion 8A preceding them with the
first motion regarding vision zero I've
received notice that councilor Welton is
to move this please councilor Walton
thank you thank you chair uh what do we
want to achieve with this motion uh
firstly we want to bring Road Safety up
the council's agenda because it needs to
be acknowledged that we've fallen behind
the government's projections for
reductions in casualty numbers in the
90s and 90s Trafford saw a steady
statistical decline in its Road deaths
and serious injuries but in the decade
that followed that Decline plateaued and
even started to reverse clearly we need
a plan to get back on Trend secondly we
think that Vision zero is a great
concept that residents can easily
understand an ambition to eliminate
serious casualties on our roads by 2040
it's pretty hard to argue against and
can help win support when the council is
Consulting on its major plans to make
our roads safer and more attractive for
walking and cycling thirdly we want to
see a Target in place that will require
cross department and cross-agency
working in the same way as we're
starting to see with the climate
emergency response responsible
responsibility needs to be shared
particularly when there are so many
basic wins to be had like stopping our
waste teams leaving bins blocking
Pavements or properly enforcing parking
restrictions around schools or on Match
days
we also want to highlight the huge cost
of Road collisions crashes both reported
and unreported are estimated to cost the
UK an extraordinary 33 billion pounds a
year equivalent to 1.5 percent of GDP
what a waste finally we wanted to bring
Trafford onto the same page as other
authorities and organizations that are
adopting Vision zero targets Leeds voted
through its Vision zero strategy last
month even the Automobile Association
the AAA made Vision zero its number one
priority for the new government chair it
seems that even the motoring Lobby has
gone woke
into the amendment it's welcomed that
the council is here that council is
hearing today about the vision zero work
that is going on among directors of
Public Health at GM level and on moving
traffic offenses but we already know
that our own director of Public Health
is a supporter of vision Zero's aims
what happens if other directors of
Public Health can't agree passing
emotion supporting Vision zero would now
now would send a strong message to other
councils that Trafford is on board
because we know Vision zero is a
feasible it's been done elsewhere
despite having twice our population and
population Oslo achieved zero pedestrian
and cyclist deaths in 2019 17 years
after adopting Vision zero money is
tight but other authorities have found
ways to fund safer roads Prosecuting
moving traffic offenses workplace or out
of town on retail parking levers or
variable charging for parking permits
based on engine type or vehicle size
there are ways to get there if the
political will is there but the first
step of a successful journey is knowing
where you're going
let's not forget what's at the heart of
this Motion in traffic nearly 50 people
a year experience a fatal or potentially
life-changing crash
what would we say to them or their
families if they were in this chamber
with us now
would we pledge to do everything we can
to prevent future tragedies let's do
everything we can let's sign up to
Vision zero right now by supporting this
motion thank you chair
thank you councilor Welton is the motion
seconded
councilor Leicester yes his chair and
I'd like to reserve the right to speak
thank you
thank you
um
now at this point
we go to an amendment yes right yes we
have received an amendment from the
labor group
and therefore I think this has been
circulated much earlier than this
evening and I'll call upon councilor
adshead to speak to the amendment thank
you
thank you
we welcome the motion
and and of course we're full of support
all measures aimed at road safety and
Casualty reduction work while some work
is carried out some other local funds
usually low-cost schemes although
they'll be effective the motion needs to
be collecting and amending to take
account that as an a GM Authority most
of the study specialist work is now
looked at an accommodation-wide basis
Fuji tsgm and this does need reflecting
gfgm have the skills knowledge and
Staffing that no one individual
Authority across GM can provide for
themselves if it is an issue in one
mother it's likely to an issue across
other borders gftm of the skills and
expertise
in this specialist area and as such all
benefit all those benefit from this
joint working there was a time when such
measures finished at the lower boundary
not just talking about sideways other
safety measures as well and of course
this was complete nonsense and nothing
to help low safety thankfully but now
we've got across GM the tfgm on the
olive oil just working out that sort of
nonsense it's behind us and we can
concentrate on real world safety there
is a measures like GMO sector
partnership which can just provide a
very specialist nature with some real
gold safety schemes at least mention
about one in Stratford which before it's
implemented there was actually a whole
series of pedestrian casualties and tfgm
did this specialist work and looked it
and introduced this scheme and and since
that had been in place a number of years
now there's not been one destined
casualty there and and that's some devil
Specialists look the money from that
came from the same sort of part that is
funded through uh when a driver's commit
an offense and they go flow safety
department they go through Road Safety
awareness course it's that same sort of
funding plot and Specialists schemes can
actually be funded through this work
there's only a handful of students like
that across gem that have been funded
across the conservation and and
certainly one of those and it's what
have been held as long to successful
ones that's really helps to put
pedestrian casualties so we need to
actually really work with TFM on schemes
like this to make sure we have and
support measures we also cannot make
assumptions councilor Welton has on the
cause of accidents and from time to time
there will be blips in the figures and
we need Capital analysis to understand
why this is and not start to jump to
conclusions the trend continues to be
carried downward and I've got the
figures to show that and that's positive
though there's still always what's to be
done
Jeff gem have a number of old safety
strategies including the GM 20 40
strategy course and a whole host of
which is not going to name tonight you
know we need to keep concise and this is
always high on the agenda that is
discussed regular meetings with
transport committees and indeed officers
across the connotation that and and it's
really high is high on the agenda we
offer clear support measures I said
earlier light 20s on and obviously would
welcome looking further at Vision 20.
however we also do need to look at ways
in which this can be funded other than
along small local pots which simply is
not good enough to do these huge schemes
and tfgm is one of those sorts of areas
to Lobby including uh I'll simply also
say to council Alton that you mentioned
moving traffic offenses and whilst this
is being looked at and will be
implemented it cannot be used as a
revenue raising tool and that's clearly
set out in law so thank you mayor thank
you I second and I moved the amendment
thank you councilor ad said and the
leader of the council is to Second the
amendment counselor secondary chair and
reserve the right for now thank you
the amendment has been moved and
seconded do any members wish to speak on
the amendment
councilor Williams
councilor Williams Council Williams the
floor is yours thank you chair um I just
wanted to provide
um council with a small amount of
supplementary information following
Council assets intervention much of the
work that is conducted on road safety is
carried out a connotation-wide level
through greater Manchester combined
Authority as trafford's representative
on greater Manchester transport
committee I did query the increase in
KSI statistic reported
figures at the last committee meeting we
have since had a report back advising
that the reason that there's been such a
dramatic increase recently is because of
reporting mechanism and I'd just like to
quote from section 3.5 of the committee
report that we'll be looking at on
Friday's meeting of Greater Manchester
transport committee where it says the
road reduction
um
action plan devote danger reduction
action plan outlines an ambition to
adopt Vision zero in Greater Manchester
Vision zero is a worldwide Vision with
several counties having already adopted
it counties within the UK have now
started to adopt Vision zero for
themselves including Transport for
London Devon and Cornwall Oxford
Brighton and Kent
the road reduction the road danger
reduction action plan will support
Vision zero and help greater Manchester
achieve our vision of no deaths and
serious injuries on our roads it's
anticipated that this work will be
progressed in the next 12 months so I'd
hope that we'd have a more meaningful
update for you as as the year progresses
councilor thank you
thank you councilor Williams
um if there's no one else wants to speak
to the amendment councilor Wilton has
the right to respond to discussion thus
far
I'm okay thank you very much thank you I
appreciate the comments from the uh from
the executive members though thank you
in which case I can now put the
amendment to the vote all those in favor
of the amendment
all those against
all the
um abstentions
so the amendment is carried and now
becomes the substantive motion
do any counselors wish to speak on what
is now the substantive motion councilor
new gosh that's got his hand up
councilor Leicester
start with councilor newgrass thank you
thank you man
this motion talks of road safety
statistics I would like to take a moment
to speak of just one of those
councils I wonder if you remember what
you were doing back on Monday the 18th
of July
it was the first of those two sweltering
hot days during the 40 degree heat wave
it was also the last few days of school
for the long summer holidays
I was at home in my office talking to a
client on Zoom through my office window
I could see school children from bth
making their way home crossing over
Oldfield Road in front of my house
towards alternate interchange nothing
unusual at all
during that Zoom call my attention is
drawn to just how quiet it has become
outside I look up
all the traffic had stopped drivers were
out of their cars school children
usually usually boisterously making
their way home were stood in groups some
sat on the pavement head in their hands
the look of shock and despair clear on
many faces
the silence was broken by the whale of
sirens many sirens
moments earlier a large black Range
Rover weighing over two tons traveling
down Oldfield Road was in collision with
a 12 year old schoolgirl
she was currently on the road fighting
for her life attended to by first aiders
the emergency service response was Swift
and extensive possibly a dozen police
the Fast Response medic an ambulance
followed finally by the air ambulance
it took them a very long time to
stabilize that child a worryingly long
time
the child survived but I'm told she
suffered catastrophic life-changing
injuries
14 years earlier at the very same spot
in an almost identical Collision it
resulted in a fatality
counselors we cannot prevent every
accident nor can we keep everyone safe
but this Council sets targets for many
things Financial targets carbon
reduction targets and today I implore
you let us commit to this road casualty
reduction Target across Trafford thank
you Mr Mayor
thank you councilor new brush call on
councilor Leicester to speak thank you
thank you mayor to get around in a safe
and healthy manner is everyone's human
right wherever or whoever we are no one
should be killed or seriously injured on
the roads
I'd like to speak to this motion based
on my personal experience having worked
for many years as a neurological
physiotherapist in a community
Rehabilitation team
I've seen firsthand or too many times
the impact of serious Road collisions
these have been people who are drivers
cyclists pedestrians people of all ages
and backgrounds I've seen so many
different outcomes but one thing that
comes to mind is a young man who has
left tetraplegic after a road Collision
he was unable to do anything for himself
and require 24-hour care packages for
the rest of his life
the personal impact on a young man who
had his life destroyed and on his
parents who had been at the point of
retirement had given up everything to
care for him to give to give everything
up to care of him was absolutely
Dreadful
what really it brings home to me is the
financial cost of providing that level
of care for what could be for decades
there's also been lots of taxes and
contribution that that young man could
have made had he been able to work and
that's just one person I could give you
so many stories the course both human
and economic is unacceptable
we talk about the financial cost of the
actions needed to achieve the vision
zero Target but when you look at the
cost to the NHS and of supporting people
with serious life-changing injuries how
can we say that we can't afford it when
we look at the costings for this for the
measures needed to bring Vision zero
about we must ensure that we balance
again it against the cost to Society of
deaths and serious injuries on the road
due to bad driving and poor
infrastructure the savings from not
needing to provide this level of care
would quickly support the changes needed
to make our strength our roads safer and
that's why we would call on the council
to make an absolute commitment to this
motion and to Vision zero thank you
thank you Council Lester understand
councilor but wishes to speak thank you
thank you Mr Mayor
speaking on the motion the little that's
come out in terms of specifics on this
and we were talking about what cities
and regions and states I know this
wouldn't be invention of a few cities
there now but uh there's no comparative
data and costs that have been uh
factored a lot of the enforcement would
impose substantial costs on the taxpayer
we talk about funding from a section 106
agreements would not be enough and it
would wouldn't it's only mainly used for
mitigating planning schemes in the areas
affected
amongst other things so
grant funding is already being directed
to Priority environmental projects much
of the work is already being progressed
at local Regional and National Level
under various programs to exercise in
environmental and safety improvements in
a sustainable way
so in its current form can't support
this motion thank you Patrick mayor
thank you councilor Buck now before I
move to asking councilor Welton whether
we finally wanted to speak on what is
now the amended substantive motion I've
got an idea that I should ask the leader
whether he wanted to exercise his right
reply which apparently not so councilor
Walton do you wish to say anything
further before we go to oh vote thank
you thank you chair uh briefly and I
I speak to a lot of members lots of my
fellow councilors and one thing that we
do talk about a lot is is road safety
and I do know that that it's something
that everybody would like to do
something
um about and I really appreciate I do
appreciate this as this amendment is
genuinely a um a friendly amendment I do
know that so many of the councilors
would like to would like to would like
to do more and I very much look forward
to seeing what happens with the um uh
with the with this at GMC level I would
like to say something um I I was hoping
that councilor newgross would raise that
particular case
and what I would say about that
particular case is it brings into Focus
what we do after a serious accident
um or not an accent a crash sorry a
collision
um in that particular case nothing has
happened to restrict what the car
drivers what the drivers on that road
are doing
we haven't put in a temporary speed
limit on there a temporary 20 mile an
hour limit or something like that the
only thing that's happened at the moment
is we've put in more barriers more
barriers that restrict where people can
cross the road okay and this has been
this this is the history of road safety
efforts in this country is that we're
always restricting the vulnerable Road
user and never the driver and this is
what really really needs to change about
our our approach when there is a serious
fatality we need to look with urgency at
that at that
um
that particular Road layout that road
Network needs to be done soon not years
after after that and hopefully with this
new approach we can get there in
combination with our GMC allies thank
you thank you councilor welcome for your
final remarks so I can now put the
motion which is effectively the amended
and now substantive motion to the vote
all those in favor
all those against
abstentions
thank you and that motion as amended is
now carried uh I might add that I am
meeting tomorrow and an event with all
the other Mayors so I'll ask them how
they're getting on with this topic in
their boroughs it's a transport day out
would you believe so it's quite appetite
as well so moving rapidly on motion 9B
the next motion this evening is about
the energy and cost of living crisis and
is to be moved by councilor Hartley
please thank you
thank you chair it's easy to blame our
energy crisis on the war in Ukraine and
there's no doubt that this has increased
the wholesale price of gas
but a crisis that our energy security is
one that's been predicted for many years
and this government has done precious
little about it
we're really quick to weather this
crisis with 40 of our energies still
coming from natural gas the government
could have invested more in Renewables
and ended our dependence on gas there's
another crisis that demanded this action
and that's the climate crisis the
government is failing to meet its
responsibilities to move to Net Zero
the support on energy bills announced by
the government recently is of course
welcome but it's too little too late our
new prime minister is so far removed
from reality that she thinks that no
family has to pay more than two and a
half thousand pounds for their energy
which of course is not true average
household bills have risen from 1100
pounds in April 2021 to two and a half
thousand pounds now and this crisis hits
our most vulnerable residents the
hardest four million of our poorest
households are on prepayment meters and
that means they're usually on the
highest tariffs and the resolution
Foundation estimates that for these
households their bills in January will
amount to half of their disposable
income and they'll have to pay those
costs up front there's little help for
trafford's businesses like a small
catering business in Ashland mersey that
received the news this week that their
electricity bill had doubled
despite the government's Assistance or
the small Hospitality business in Ashton
has seen their energy bill go from 400
pounds per month to 1 000 pounds per
month and this is on top of the cost of
supplies doubling and that's where they
can get them for the first time in 12 or
13 years of trading for both of these
businesses they can see no future and
behind every small business is someone's
livelihood and a key part of our
communities the government could have
invested in the program to rapidly
insulate our homes moving from an energy
performance certificate Band F to band C
would save an average of 968 pounds per
year just on gas we have some of the
leakeiest homes in Europe there can be
no greater National Mission than to
avert this climate crisis than this the
government could have invested in gas
storage facilities so we're less reliant
on market prices for gas but instead our
largest gas storage facility closed in
2017 a decision approved by the then
Chief Secretary of to the treasury Liz
truss there are plans to reopen it but
it needs repairs and its capacity for
this winter will only be 10 of its
potential as a small fraction of the
storage capacity of countries like
Germany and the Netherlands
the government could have invested in
onshore wind power but instead it ended
subsidies for this in 2016 and it's
effectively banned now as local
communities can veto any planning
consent the government could have
invested in solar power but solar was
excluded from government support in 2015
and the latest news is the government
planned to ban solar Farms
so what's the government's solution to
this crisis well there's the prospect of
electricity being Russian this winter
but their Solutions otherwise are to
increase drilling for gas and oil in the
North Sea Jacob breeze-mogg recently
affirming that we would extract every
ounce of oil and gas from the North Sea
and there's the proposal to restart
fracking both of these will worsen our
climate crisis and more on that later I
think as with so many issues we've had
Tory government to sleep at the wheel
obsessed with an ideological drive for
austerity brexit and no tax cuts for the
richest rather than dealing with our
climate crisis and our energy security
crisis 12 years of conservative failure
on energy Security on Renewables on
storage on insulation and on fixing our
broken energy Market once again ordinary
families will pay the price for this
failure and it will be left to a labor
government to pick up the pieces and
deal with these crises and from speaking
to presence in Trafford that day cannot
come soon enough I so move the chair
thank you
thank you councilor Hartley uh councilor
Harding is to second the motion
thank you
thank you mayor
a lot has been said over recent weeks
and months about the impact of the cost
of living crisis on our residents and
communities
the fear of not being able to switch the
heating on as the weather gets colder
the fear of not being able to get to
work as the pay packet is just not
stretching far enough at the end of the
month to fill the car with fuel the fear
that your kids are going hungry or the
shoes that have holes in and are letting
water in will just have to last that
little bit longer
and I want to focus on some of the wider
implications of this cost of living
crisis
I was in London yesterday at the cross
party LGA Community wellbeing board
not a single politician around that
table wasn't worried or concerned about
the coming months and coming weeks and
months and what lies ahead
it was accepted by everyone that this
cost of living crisis will bike deep and
hard and the impact on the health of our
residents will be harsh mainly on those
already experiencing poverty
yet further inequality for them and we
know from extensive International
evidence
that this will cause higher levels of
mental ill health in a society
and this is especially the case when
people with the least wealth are facing
bigger struggles to survive day to day
and seeing their incomes fall further
the stigma around poverty is insidious
feckless lazy let me tell you this
crisis is not the fault of our residents
or our staff
it lies squarely at the door of this
government they have pursued with
abandon austerity measures
which have decimated local government
and those vital support services that
people need at a time like this
I have queued up at the bread and butter
thing van on a Friday following my third
redundancy in five years
I have had to have a payment plan for my
council tax following my job loss as a
result of covid
poverty and the fear of poverty is real
it has consequences of the mental
well-being of our residents
substance misuse rates Rose sharply
during the 2008 financial crisis
substance misuse and addiction such as
gambling are coping mechanisms for some
during a crisis
as economic uncertainty job insecurity
and general anxiety about the future
take hold we should be very concerned
about how the next few months will play
out
warm homes nutritious food and a stable
job are vital building blocks for health
in addition to the effect of cold homes
on mental and physical illness living on
a low income does much damage if we are
constantly worrying about making ends
meet it puts strains on our bodies
resulting in increased stress with
effects on the heart and blood vessels
and a distort disordered immune system
this type of living environment will
mean thousands of people will die
earlier than they should
those are the words of Michael Marmot
the renowned expert on the impact of
poverty on health
I am very proud of the work that this
labor Council our community hubs and
partners across Trafford are doing to
support our residents and staff at a
time of great uncertainty
and I know that you all share that
Community passion as I saw many of you
at the vaccine clinics and the winter
well packing sessions last year
that's why I hope that you're going to
do the right thing tonight and you're
going to support this motion and send a
message to this government thank you
chair
thank you councilor Harding
um I have received notice of an
amendment to this motion I invite
councilor Ennis
to move this now but I'm also aware of
an addendum that's been put forward by
the labor group that I think
um
the uh
councilor Ennis or whoever's actually
going to speak might be wishing to
accept that's my understanding of it
perhaps you can clear us all up on that
one yes thank you Mr Man can I start by
acknowledging the addendum that was
circulated by the labor group the
liberal Democrat group supports it and
is very happy to do so and invite
Council to to do the same
last year when this Council won funding
to provide winter care packages I went
door-to-door in timpley village with
Council newgrash to deliver them
and I saw just how much some people
needed that support 12 months ago I want
to thank everyone who was involved in
last year's scheme
and I welcome the press release which
I've seen today issued by the council
announcing winter Welles and cuts for
vulnerable people
when I see the cost of living crisis in
the news I think about the families in
Village Ward who were just about
managing before the conservatives lost
control of the economy and allowed
energy bills to Skyrocket I think about
the social worker and single mother of
two who keeps the whole family in one
room three months out of the year just
to keep her bills down
I think about the pensioners living
alone who can't afford to keep the car
but have no other way to get to the
shops
12 months ago these were the people who
were just about managing to keep their
head above water
now they are being plunged into fuel
poverty by the conservatives cost of
living crisis
so while the council Council can do
every can't do everything these are the
people we should be we should be
pressing ahead in support of this winter
because it stays in the motion it
doesn't have to be this way I
passionately believe in local
government's ability to help these
people
to make a real measurable and positive
impact from the bottom up
our covid response demonstrated that
councils can show leadership in a crisis
especially when it is so disastrously
lacking from central government
I know from experience the difference it
makes to our residents when their
Council occurs enough to go the extra
mile and these care packages will go the
extra mile Mr Mayor they are something
which will make a real difference
because it shows whose side we're on as
a council now conservatives have shown
whose side they're on
they want to help big businesses bankers
and billionaires this amendment and this
motion puts the Council on the side of
ordinary people who will struggle this
winter because the government is failing
them I hope colleagues will support the
amendment
thank you councilor Ennis uh councilor
frass is to Second the amendment please
thank you Mr Mayor this cost of living
crisis is about choices the government
are trying to convince everyone that
this economic turmoil is something which
is just happening to us they point to
the war in Ukraine they blame kovid they
claim every country is in the same
situation
but the conservatives made a choice to
help energy bosses bankers and
billionaires they made a choice to
neglect the most vulnerable in society
the very fact that our European
neighbors have made such radically
different choices proves the UK is not
some helpless victim of circumstance
it's deliberately driven into this
crisis by a government that's lost
control of the economy plunge more
people into poverty and left local
councils to plug the Gap this amendment
addresses one of those gaps and voting
in favor will show that we understand
political choices matter
thank you councilor fresh are there any
councilors wish to speak on this
amendment including the addendum which
is tapped into it the leader does
councilor Wright
um George counselor right first or
yourself leader councilor Wright thank
you
thank you mayor and obviously I do speak
in support of this motion I'm imagining
the Tory group will tonight vote to
abstain from this motion
um I very much doubt they will so
overtly dismiss the concerns of millions
of people across the country like their
prime minister did however I also very
much doubt they will have the bottle to
vote with labor and against their own
government despite this being the right
thing to do maybe I'll be proven wrong
prime minister trust has been in place
for 37 days
in that time not only is she refused to
increase benefits with inflation and by
the way that's not an increase in
benefits that sorry I'll start again
that's not an increase in benefits thus
is simply a decision that would mean
people can keep up with prices
no one will be better off
perish the thought that everyday working
people would actually be better off
under a Tory government
these people would only be getting
enough to keep up with General inflation
that doesn't include food inflation
which is well above that level and other
services which are much higher than the
current figure
this prime minister has also decided the
best way to grow the economy is to bring
back that old Tory Playbook strategy
trickle down economics in doing so of
course she has crushed the economy put
people's homes at risk of repossession
and led to the unprecedented
intervention from the bank of England
she's crashed the pound against the
dollar
briefed about scrapping the government's
intentions to remove no fault evictions
and then rode back on that today she's
removed the 45
45p rate and reinstated it she's removed
the cap on Bankers bonuses an absolute
priority at a time like this I'm sure
you will agree and of course now also
once once growth growth and more growth
maybe she was talking about the labor
leading the opinion polls and not the
economy that is some achievement in 37
days
this isn't a crisis this is an emergency
unless we put cash into people's pockets
people will lose their homes their
businesses and their livelihoods
the knock-on effect is local economies
crash our retailers go out of business
and our town centers become ghost towns
our demand as counselor Harding said on
Voice or services such as the NHS social
Care Mental Health support and Drug and
Alcohol Services outstrips Supply
it's quite simple if you don't provide
an economy where the average working
person can afford the very basics in
life and support the local economy
around them you bankrupt an area unless
this government takes his head out of
the sand scraps its ideological Crusade
the residents of Trafford are going to
feel the full brunt of this emergency do
the right thing and vote in favor of
this motion tonight thank you chair yeah
thank you councilor Wright leader
thank you I was going to stand up and
say that normally with emotion like this
I'd come out on the attack and criticize
the government I was going to say I'm
not going to do that because the people
of this country are well aware where the
fault lies in this but actually I can
simply say now that councilor Wright has
done it for me so instead I want to
focus briefly on some elements of our
response in supporting our community
that aren't directly referenced in this
motion because I cannot begin to
articulate how proud I am of our staff
our partners in particular our community
hubs in the work and the support that
they are doing and providing
to look after those struggling in
Trafford amidst this cost of living
crisis so if I think about things that
aren't mentioned in the motion of which
the winter warmer packs would have been
won but the amendment has come forward
seeking Clarity that they will be
provided and I'm very proud to say that
they will be but our money advice
referral tool is now up and running our
single points of contact phone number
into the cab a free phone number is now
up and running an extra seventy thousand
pounds put in to support our welfare
rights service and the citizens advice
Bureau whose case loads are spiraling as
a result of the decisions that this
government has made
and an extra hundred thousand pounds
repurposed to support our community hubs
who did such a good job for us during
the covid crisis what we Face a crisis
of equal proportions now people who
would not usually think that they would
be affected by an economic crisis such
as this people who are perhaps not on
low incomes but whose mortgage has gone
up by several hundred pounds a month
people whose energy bills have spiraled
out of control so we will stand up our
living rooms to make sure that they have
a warm safe place to go comfortable
seating where no money is accepted for
anything but hot drinks and hot meals
will be available the message that I
want to send out tonight is not one of
political knock about it is one that
says that this council is on the side of
our residence in this crisis we will do
all we can to support them yes times are
hard here yes the cost of living crisis
has punched a six million pound hole in
our in-year budget and near doubled our
budget gap for next year but let
counselor Ross's hair fall out on that
not our residence because actually chair
we do need to say to our residents we're
here for you we're on our side on your
side we'll do everything that we can to
support you because this is going to be
until six months and as things look at
the moment this may go way beyond that
so I'll leave it there Chair by saying
Trafford Council stands with those who
need our help and support and we affirm
tonight hopefully all of us that we will
do everything we can thank you
thank you leader
um councilor Hartley has the right of
reply before we put this amendment to
the vote
uh nothing I need Amendment chair thank
you thank you councilor Hartley I'll now
put the amendment to the vote all those
in favor
all those against
abstentions
right right
that's with the that's the amended
motion with the addendum which was put
into cope I believe with probably a
press release this afternoon that we've
all seen as well
um
we've had quite a lot of discussion thus
far and I think we know where this
debate is going
um does councilor Hartley wish to say
anything further we before we put now
this new substantive motion to the vote
and we've got councilor Coggins would
like to speak off you go thank you
um thank you chair um the green group
are happy to support the labor motion
tonight although there are places where
we believe it doesn't go far enough
um we need to highlight first of all the
um the claim we all know is true in
there that energy providers such as BP
and shell continue to make massive
profits despite the damage they're doing
to our environment and anytime those
names are mentioned in this chamber I'm
afraid I become a broken record and have
to remind you all that actually BP and
shell are being propped up
um directly by Trafford Council and
there's one billion pound of Greater
Manchester pension fund money
um is in these big fossil fuel companies
with BP and shell being named as two of
the biggest beneficiaries and it's hard
for most of us to get around our heads
around exactly how much a billion pounds
is but it really is a lot of money and
we have to remember that this is against
a background for other councils and
public sector Pension funds like Walton
Forest Council who have this same
fiduciary duties as we have and have now
uh more or less completely divested and
so whilst we agree what it says there we
just have to remember that while it's
easy to call on the government to do the
right thing it's important that we are
are are taking whatever actions we can
here as well
um we completely support the um calls in
the in the in the motion
um I wanted to highlight the
reintroduction of the 20 pound uplift in
Universal Credit in fact green party
thinks that this needs to go further and
we would like to see this doubled to a
40 pounds um uplift
um reverting to the levels of income
people have had in the past is actually
not enough looking at the levels of
inflation we're facing right now
um as cancer Hartley has said a tax on
the richest is not the way to deal with
uh sorry reducing taxes for the richest
is not the way to deal with this we need
a fairer more compassionate economy and
we actually need higher taxes on the
riches and on those big companies
especially a dirty profits tax on those
fossil fuel companies that are that are
bringing us so many of these problems
and but in the longer run we need to
actually introduce a universal basic
income as the only way of really dealing
in a permanent way with these problems
and we Face the cost of living crisis
cost of working crisis fuel poverty food
poverty period poverty pensioner poverty
child poverty working age poverty we
need to recognize the poverty itself is
the problem and the poverty is a
political choice
um in the sort of fair and compassionate
economy that we need to move to we need
uh to live in a country where people are
not subject to these sort of
fluctuations and only a universal basic
income could guarantee that people know
they will be able to put food on their
table and have a warm safe home to go
home to
So currently our economy isn't working
for people and it also isn't working for
the planet and those two aren't
unrelated the food crisis the cost of
living crisis and the climate crisis are
two sides of the same coin so the
measures in this motion we agree with
but we see them only as sticking
plasters trying to give us partial
short-term repairs to a broken system
when it's greens we want to actually
change that system and bring in an
economy that is fair that works for all
of us and divestment from fossil fuels
and Universal basic income are core
parts of making that work thank you
thank you councilor Coggins just before
I do go to councilor Hartley for a final
word is there anyone else wants to put
their hand up there is one councilor
wetton go on
Mr I've I've listened to everything
that's been said in this debate uh and
various other debates tonight the main
um mainly talking about what what just
been said in this debate
and and we all know these debates are
too too often again to catch each other
out and uh councilor right even sort of
spelled it out for us with how we're
going to vote and all that that sort of
thing
um
I'm going to just
break with formality and I'm just going
to share this with
with this Council
that I can see perfectly clearly the
the Specter of the crisis
that many homes are facing in this boat
and Beyond
and that doesn't sit comfortably with me
I'm not some well-watted Tory or
whatever the names that want to be flung
about
I'm going to tell you that I make
representations to government
especially when I'm not happy with how
they're performing
and I have made representations
strong representations recently
the most recent one was today
I don't work for big business
I don't work for billionaires or bankers
and
I named some of those in my
representations to government
now I can't share my representations
with you
but I can tell you that they have been
very firmly stated
not least because they needed to be
firmly stated
so with those few words I'll sit down
thank you
thank you councilor wetton
I did now I had counselor but briefly
put his hand up I'm not sure if he does
want to speak having heard that from
councilor wetton and
well there won't be a motion after this
we're coming to the end of it and we've
got councilor Holden wants to speak as
well so can you perhaps be brief each of
you thank you
thank you Mr Mayor uh
just to point out on one of the the
things that councilor Western
talks about some of the services that
are provided I think there needs to be a
little bit more transparency in being
able to say where the government that
the funding is coming from I mean
there's a lot of things that are funded
by the government which don't seem to
make it through into uh the media so I
think it's important that is
differentiated as I can carry on much of
the concerns
are now being addressed by the
government I mean yes the worldwide
impact of kovid and consequent recession
will be with us for some time
unfortunately and felt by local councils
across the country and on National
budgets
the economy needs to be energized to
support the uh the economy and the
public in terms of taxes uh generated
this motion for a demands list to the
government is already being addressed
amongst with many other issues which are
constantly being reviewed by the
government under difficult social and
economic conditions because we have real
concerns for our residents so uh I'll
just leave it at that thank you thank
you councilor but councilor Holden
foreign
what I'm about to say is from me it is
not my party's views I don't know what
that is frankly
I personally as I did last year will
support any activity that this Council
deems to be necessary in terms of
supporting its most vulnerable people
I'll deliver the parcels I'll turn up at
the hubs and make the tea because we do
care
but you've also heard me say that I
really do consider myself to be a bear
of little brain sometimes
and what I can't get my head around is
what change you think central government
are going to make
as a result of the speeches that we've
heard from the labor group tonight
criticizing everything that they've
tried to do will it make an iota
of difference I don't think it will but
even if it doesn't
we're here to provide that support
to provide that work in the trenches to
do whatever we can for our residents to
get through this very very difficult
time thank you so much thank you Council
Holden before we go back to councilor
Hartley I know leader would like to say
just a few more words
thanks chair I'm somewhat confused to
hear from somebody giving a speech that
he thinks all speeches in this place are
a waste of time but nonetheless I will
do my best to comment firstly in
response to councilor but I am more than
happy counselor but to document every
item that the government funds this
Council for in specific packages
provided I can include at the beginning
of it after removing a total of 243
million pounds from this Council since
2010 the government has given us five
thousand pounds towards Project X or
project y if you want to take me up on
that deal you just pop me an email but
we will always if we're going down that
route tell the true picture and we'll
include details of the budget challenges
that we face in this Council as a direct
result of the government's approach to
austerity and general these days
economic mismanagement I also just want
to say very briefly that councilor but
told us that the
um the list in this motion was being
addressed by government so I do look
forward to the introduction of an urgent
and accessible insulation program I look
forward to targeted assistance for
schools hospitals and other public
buildings with the cuts that one minute
the government are going to make and
then today at pmqs they're not I'm
somewhat skeptical of the prime
minister's Proclamation but I'm hopeful
because you've told us that it's going
to be addressed and I also look forward
to the reintroduction of the 20 pound
Universal Credit uplift because you've
told us that these this is being
addressed as well councilor but so I am
delighted that the conservative group
are fully attuned chair
to the cost of living crisis and the
government's response to it but the
reality is
that they are simply deluded in their
response this evening the one person
whose contribution I could respect was
councilor wessons except that I don't
think it's acceptable when the
government is knowingly and repeatedly
tanking our economy to make those
representations in private rather than
letting the several thousand people that
you represent know your views
counciloret and it's all very well to
say that you'll be critical behind
closed doors but that suggests that you
understand the scale of this crisis and
I'd simply say and we'll see how people
vote tonight we'll get a fair idea of
who is prepared to acknowledge it in
public this evening thank you chair
thank you leader and finally I think
move to councilor Hartley to final
Awards do you wish
just just one point which was raised by
councilor Coggins I think about the
prophets made by BP and shell I do agree
with you on that they receive more money
back from the government than they're
paying tax they've paid almost no tax
over recent years and that's why
laborers propose the further windfall
levy on the oil and gas companies as a
way of funding this because I think as
other people have said that the problem
with the support the government are
offering is it is too little too late
and it's all being paid for by the
taxpayer so the taxpayer is making up
for this government's mistakes and uh I
think we'll we'll see how people really
feel and how strongly they feel when we
take about an emotion thank you
thank you councilor Hartley we can now
move to putting the
amended addended
motion to the vote all those in favor
all those against
abstentions
thank you
moving on
motion 9C the next motion concerns
Asbestos and is to be moved by councilor
Thomas please thank you thank you mayor
health and safety executive estimates
that 1.3 million trades people an
emergency service Personnel are still at
risk of exposure or contact with
asbestos up to 100 times per year we
still have 5 000 deaths annually 2 340
of these deaths are from mesothelioma
and approximately three quarters of
those suffers are men
the UK and Australia have the highest
rates of mesothelioma in the world
without action we will continue to hold
the number one spot
while asbestos all types were finally
banned from building use in 1999 there
are many thousands of public buildings
including town halls workplaces and over
75 percent of schools
they still have asbestos within them
well as many sites were supposedly made
safe any disturbance could release a
small number of strands to come Airborne
it takes one strand of asbestos to cause
these diseases
Sid Lark never smoked
he worked at Glen Eagles golf course and
shell chemicals he worked within
plasterboards he was an electrician in
April 2012 he was diagnosed with
mesothelioma
on January the 4th 2013 he died age 73.
Kathy Whitby was an office worker never
had any dealings on his pastors she
married a builder in the gender roles of
the 70s she did the household laundry
her contact was via her husband's
overalls which carried asbestos 12
months after diagnosis she passed away
age 68.
Penny was a primary school in the early
80s
and the building next to her school in
Salford was demolished
according to her doctors the asbestos in
that building became airborne and she
probably inhaled it in the playroom
playground she died 30 years later in
her early 40s leaving two children
Penny was my wife's friend
Kath Whitby was my aunt Sidler was my
father
deaths in the over 70s are still rising
life expectancy of sufferers is 12 to 21
months and the disease leads to terrible
suffering and a very painful death
is preventable
by removing or eradicating asbestos
the control of asbestos regulations came
into force on the 6th of April 2012
changed to take into account the
European commission's view that the UK
had not fully implemented the 2090u
directive on exposures to asbestos
the cost of clearing the asbestos is
beyond the purchase of public buildings
and some workplaces and the exact
numbers that have asbestos is unknown
and this is why it's imperative that
funding is made available to help the
removal and a compulsory National
register held by government
imposed
the UK nationalist bachelor's register
have a voluntary register excellent work
but not enough
due to the cost of removal is accepted
that substance isolation is adequate it
is not
the cost of the NHS in treatment and
support of sufferers is upwards of sixty
thousand pounds per person per annum
annually 300 million and that's only
including the 5 000 that die
not including new sufferers
this does not account for government or
Council financial support
the average cost of small site removal a
thousand pounds
large site two thousand five hundred
pounds upwards by having a work in
register and crucially the support for
all properties affected by this material
it will quickly reduce hundreds of
millions spent each year in treatment if
we are allocate asbestos we eradicate
the cause of these diseases and
subsequently these diseases themselves
they're no longer will thousands of
people including my father
no longer the need to die due to
ignorance ineffective management or in
different employers
as it's sadly been the case for so many
decades it is simply not good enough
that Parliament is remaining inactive
and ineffective in combating this killer
and I ask that the council do not sell
their hands on this one vote to support
this motion thank you
thank you councilor Thomas and councilor
Patel is to second the motion thank you
thank you man my colleague councilor
Thomas has set out a very compelling
case for supporting this motion for me
it's a matter of Common Sense and
justice as 20 Tradesmen continue to die
each week as a result of past exposure
until grief continues to pass through
generations I expect like councilor
Thomas many of you here have also lost
someone to asbestos exposure to I recall
the moment my granddad announced he was
going to the doctor's nervously my nan
joked it must be serious
it's a tragedy that the UK hasn't
embarked on any meaningful program of
removal whilst buildings which contain
asbestos are compelled to manage it with
no plan to remove it any of it and no
obligatory National register how can we
understand the scale of the problem
asbestos still kills around 5000 workers
each year so topically for this meeting
this is more than the number of people
killed on our roads
whilst we have known of the dangers for
decades it was the campaigning by
victims families that led to change that
changed to changing the law that saw it
finally banned it is not however just a
problem of the past it can be present
today in any building built or
refurbished before the year 2000 the
campaign to protect workers from
asbestos is not over and the threat to
working people that asbestos presents
has not gone away and for those reasons
we welcome your support for this motion
thank you
thank you councilor Patel uh councilors
who wish to speak councilor minis Holden
but
I'm aware of some support for this
generally speaking Menace
but
Holden I can begin with councilor minis
please thank you
thank you Matt
the level Cup group will be in support
we are in supports this motion
asbestos was used in insulation flooring
and Roofing prior to 1999 when it was
banned when left alone it's not harmful
however when you damage it disturb it
you know effectively
alter it in some sort of way where it is
it can release fine dust containing
asbestos fibers the fibers enter the
lungs and damaged tissue over time it
stays in the lungs it doesn't come out
long-term exposure to the fibers leads
to asbestos
asbestosis sorry a long-term lung
condition
and all money Associated conditions with
that on the health and safety regulation
we have a duty of care to those who may
be exposed to the dangerous materials
other dangerous materials including
asbestos to register where it is and to
plan removal is a sensible method to
remove the health risk to anybody who
has to work with it when it's in public
buildings like schools when it's not
just the the people who are working with
it it's also the people who are around
it so I think this is this is a sensible
way to go forward and we'll be in
support thank you
thank you councilor minis councilor butt
thank you Mr Mayor I just wanted to say
that uh as as a child I used to play on
certain Fields you know where there was
asbestos
um I I suppose I feel fortunate that uh
in those days it wasn't recognized as a
disease or a danger so I'm I'm just
grateful that I'm still here so to speak
uh certainly say you know this this some
work to be done in terms of uh
how to
I suppose control it contain it as well
in certain situations but obviously that
uh that in principle that's what we want
it to try and get asbestos removed as
best as possible so we as a group will
be supporting this motion thank you
thank you councilor Buck councilor
Holden
thank you Samir a few moments ago I
exposed myself through partner
expression as a bear with little brain
that's not a problem now this is what I
believe certain members of our society
would call a no-brainer
absolutely a no-brainer and I will have
great pleasure in supporting this I
would I've just been doing some counting
on my fingers
40 years ago
I moves with my then employers into a
brand new office building
within weeks
we were separated from certain parts of
that that building by people with
plastic screens protective suits to
remove asbestos
40 years ago
what are we doing
what have we done what will we do
regardless of how
influential I think this vote might be
I've got absolutely no problem in voting
for it wholeheartedly thank you thank
you councilor Holden does anyone else
wish to speak on the motion before I ask
councilor Thomas if he wishes to sum up
by reply
thank you Chef just briefly in 1898
Council Holden the HMS emergency
inspector of factories warned about the
dangers asbestos as over 120 years ago
bye thank everybody for the support if
that's how we're going to vote tonight
thank you very much
thank you councilor Thomas can we take a
vote on this all those in favor of this
motion as written
is there anybody against
are there any abstentions that's
unanimous thank you and I just would
reflect everybody this is in case you
didn't know one of the reasons why
General insurance companies have to keep
their records for 70 years it's not
likely the Inland revenue for seven
years it's like they have to keep them
for 70 years for just such cases as this
where people have claims which can go
back that length of time and they need
to know who the insurers were for
certain work that people did
so the final motion is in the hands of
councilor Jones and he was going to move
this final motion concerning fracking
councilor Jones
thank you mayor can you hear me fine
yeah
yeah the reason I'm reason raising this
motion at this Council today is because
on the 22nd of September this year Jacob
Bruce MOG indicated the suspension of
fracking in the UK would end as part of
the new government's growth
strategy and parts of their solutions
for energy the energy crisis is
important energy Security on gas in the
UK
fracking was last discussed as a motion
at this Council only in November 2018
when it was approved with a unanimous
consent of the council so why discuss it
again tonight
this motion is necessary as the new Tory
leadership order intent on ignoring
their 2019 Manifesto commitment to
suspend fracking in the UK because of
uncertainties about earthquakes
in the absence of a general election at
this time it's important that Trafford
and other local councils in Greater
Manchester and the northwest of England
reaffirm their opposition to fracking
in their days and sends an important
message to this government on fracking
respecting their residents wishes and
protecting the environment and hopefully
lead to another u-turn
there's several good reasons include new
uncertainty about fracking and its
Associated earthquakes why fracking
should not occur firstly it's
geologically unsuitable for the UK and
Europe
in an article in the guardian on the
25th of September a founder of quadrilla
and geologist Chris Cornelius said
fracking in the UK will only be will be
impossible of at any meaningful scale
and will not help the energy crisis
uh professor John Stern from Oxford
Institutes of energy studies went
further and said research 10 years ago
has concluded fracking wasn't viable in
Europe and it was still the case
the problem is you don't know if you
have a worthwhile resource until you've
dug 50 to 100 Wells
and that's a huge problem in Europe and
especially in the UK
that's because in Europe generally the
last the land is more crowded and it's
just not suitable because of the
connotations and more it's been more
expansive in the US because they've got
more land
so that's the reason it's become of
success in the United States and places
like Canada
secondly it's viability
not less there's problems with geology
fracking's practical implementation is
Highly Questionable in Europe and the UK
and probably making it
economically unviable it's almost
certain that's the only small amount of
gas would be extracted making little
impact on energy security or the price
consumers
um pay the size of cost of extraction
there are costs to the local environment
huge costs fracking would leave scars on
areas that have been frapped and we
don't want that and thirdly and very
importantly the UK's Net Zero commitment
it's important amongst the energy
security aspects that we now face to be
moving away from the policing a
depleting Global gas supply as fossil
fuels deliver the UK's Net Zero
commitments it makes no sense to be
desperately going around seeking out the
last remnants of gas given the Crisco
International commitment on NetZero we
should leave fossil fuels including gas
in the grounds to achieve these
commitments and achieve the UK's energy
security the labor party opposes
fraction has been very clear about this
and I know today that the conservatives
have made an amendment several
amendments to this fracking motion which
we're prepared to accept in its entirety
and we thank the conservative group for
their constructive approach on this and
we're hopefully we can have a unanimous
rejection of fracking again in Trafford
so ask our council is to reaffirm
trafford's opposition to fracking as it
is not needed not appropriate or
welcomed by residents here it's
important that we do this it's not clear
whether the government will be changing
criteria fracking to make it easier
including rules on their public consent
potentially even though we were assured
today that wouldn't be the case
planning to make it easier to for
companies to perform and there may be
changes to health and safety too we call
on all neighboring councils and the
northwest of England to do that likewise
thank you
thank you councilor Jones I'm sure
councilor Hornby has prepared something
to second the motion so uh councilor
holdenby thank you chair
I've been in support of Carl Jones's
motion
vacuum is suspended in 2019 over
concerns about the unpredictability of
Earth Tremors witnessed in Lancashire
Witnesses reported their wardrobe
shaking bad moving and thinking their
houses were going to fall down as
someone who hails from Lancashire I'm
all too aware of the stresses local
residents went through due to the
conservatives completely ignoring their
views and concerns pressing on with
fracking at the Preston new roadside
despite the clear scientific evidence of
the harm it causes the environment
residents living nearby have stated that
[ __ ] destroys lives in the land and
carrying on with it shows the government
don't care about communities
research has shown it would be years
before fracking in the UK could begin to
be produced at a viable scale by then
it'd be too late to help our residents
with the current cost living crisis
the Prime Minister this trust has
discussed giving local giving local
consent for fracking but it's not clear
about what this is or what it looks like
we need a permanent ban on fracking
our government should be focusing their
time and money on ending our dependence
on fossil fuels and building an Economy
based on 100 clean energy please support
this motion
thank you councilor Hornby
um councilor Jones has alluded to the
fact that the conservative group have
placed an amendment but has also allude
to the fact that the labor group would
be willing to support that in its
entirety um wandering councilor Z on
that basis would you be willing to
forego speaking on the amendment and we
can go straight to a vote on that and
then to a vote
we still have some speakers on the
motion itself
[Music]
as as amended
well okay well we can go to a vote on
the amendment which I think is probably
going to agree everything and then we
can discuss it at that point let's do
that let's we'll vote on the um the
amendment which I understand the labor
group will accept in its entirety so all
in favor of that
and it's a conservative right anybody
against
oh I'm now told it needs to be moved
right so
Council Z would you stand and at least
move the amendment as as written
uh thank you Mary I will not necessarily
to speak on it just to move it
yeah just to say that you move it as a
thank you and councilor Myers Miss
councilman Mars is seconding the
amendment
so you wish to now speak on the
amendment which we got the impression
everybody was in favor of well
oh but I'm not so sure you didn't put
your hands up right okay
um so
Dan Jerome councilor Jerome speaking on
the amendment Thanks Jen has moved and
seconded the green group can't support
this amendment as the Tories are simply
trying to distance themselves from this
policy much of the lines deleted are
actually true
um things have dramatically changed
since the change of leader is crossed
out but it's correct
the wrong decisions on energy have
already made yes they have and this
shouldn't be deleted
this does keep getting being brought
back by the conservative governments
also deleted but also perfectly true
the amendment does still take State the
toxic nature of fracking and the new
prime minister that's very good
but the conservatives have had since
2010 to transform our energy Supply away
from fossil fuels to Renewables and they
have utterly failed and we really can't
support this amendment we need to be
clear where the blame lies thank you
chair thank you councilor Jerome
councilor Minis
thank you mayor
this is the most bizarre Amendment
and lays bare the confusion
in the conservative party both locally
and nationally
I think councilor Holden said he wasn't
quite sure
um
for certain things as well and seems to
agree
it admits that the prime minister
that this is the motion not not Council
Holden sorry amidst the Prime Minister
thinks that fracking is an answer to
improving the UK energy security by
providing home produced gas I think
that's like homemade gas
the new chancellor has previously stated
that in a tweet the additional UK
production won't materially affect the
wholesale market price and this includes
fracking and the UK producers won't sell
Shale gas to UK consumers below the
market price
because they're not Charities well not
quite a great I agree with him actually
but you said this earlier this year as
stated by the British Geological Survey
the best case scenario would produce one
percent of UK demand so it's a drop in
the ocean
then the the this this amendment admits
that the gas should stay in the ground I
agree with that part too and asks for
the borrowers MPS to reaffirm the
rejection of fracking in Trafford now I
don't know if any of you were there but
I was at the hostings in Altrincham in
2017 for the general election that we
had and some
and uh Andrew was there and I and I and
Jane was also there and um
and and the three of us at the minimum
first hand heard uh sir Graham Brady
states that facking was environmentally
friendly now I near birth out laughing I
read and I had to contain myself because
it it was just I think it was a delivery
and the rest of it if you could imagine
him saying it
um at the time I was in the process of
installing solar panels which I have
done all over my roof or 24 of them
um so you can imagine why I just thought
it was ridiculous but yes
um we won't be supporting something so
ridiculous so I'm afraid of
abstaining on something so confused
thank you thank you councilor Minis and
I gather councilor Western leader wishes
to add something to this curious debate
thanks chair and to confirm councilor
Coggins was also present at said
hustling
um
I do just want to explain my logic to
councilors Jerome and minis because I
fully accept
that in many ways this Waters down the
original Amendment however it does not
detract from the overall message and
most importantly for me it shows up
close just how divided the conservatives
are on this issue if they push through
an amendment tonight that is going
directly against their own government's
policy so I would have thought the
Brazen politician in me that that was
something that we wanted to make as
public as possible and I can't quite
believe that they've done it but I think
that we should allow them to continue on
that particular course and it is on that
basis that I would encourage members to
support the amendment thank you chair
and I think it's on that basis I'll ask
councilor Jones whether he wishes to add
anything before we vote on the amended
motion which has been moved and seconded
yeah just briefly
um we we shouldn't denigrate the
cooperation that the conservatives tried
to do with this motion and I'm hoping
they will vote for the motion and we can
all unanimously vote it for fracking to
be opposed and
not welcome into effort thank you
I think thank you councilor Jones I
think the amendment continues the spirit
of the original motion and changes a few
capital letters doesn't it it's not it's
not a not a not a proper noun really is
it sort of
um so we're voting on the amendment
all in favor the amendment
those against
we have
four
abstentions we have five the amendment
is passed the amended motion becomes a
substantive motion does councilor Jones
wish to say anything more oily body else
right counselor
off you go
thank you chair um it's a kind of it's
kind of ironic that uh Jacob Reese smog
is gaslighting is with fracked gas
unusually I find myself with
considerable sympathy for art
conservative councilor colleagues
tonight do they support the current
conservative government or the previous
conservative government I congratulate
them for once and probably the only time
on choosing the last lot thank you
thank you so we've got councilor Holden
and councilor Brophy as well I think it
councilor Holden thank you
I'm
doubtful
about fracking but I do have
to actually declare
a potential interest
for the first third of my considerable
time on this planet
I was fed
housed and clothed by coal
my family dug it out of the ground
loaded it into trains sent it to power
stations so that the good people of
Trafford could have their electricity
and in those days their gas because we
made it with Town Gas
we have abandoned that huge energy
resource for all sorts of political
reasons which we can't go into now
but I'm still doubtful about whether or
not we should go all out
for fracking for all the reasons that
have been mentioned
and I sometimes think that we're
worrying a bit because quadrilla or a
commercial organization they aren't
going to drill and develop fields of
fract natural gas if they can't make
money out of it so let's just
keep an open mind about where it would
go and I should probably perhaps have
given some of our green friends a
trigger warning about my enthusiasm for
fossil fuel
because it's lovely thank you
all right thank you councilor Holden
councilor Brophy just for a couple of
minutes maximum
thank you mayor so I'd just like to
thank councilor Jones for bringing this
motion to Trafford because it was of
course a joint Motion in November 2018
by the liberal group and the green party
group that reaffirmed chappa's
opposition to fracking and we're now
doing that again it's very clear that
very little has changed in the last
three years other than now seeing the
catastrophic impact of climate change in
terms of more extreme and unpredictable
weather patterns
fracking is a fossil fuel intensive
process and the consequences of fracking
is harmful for our Borough
our Northwest region and to our planet
it's this current Tory government
reigniting the debate about fracking
it's a distraction
because fracking will not solve the
current energy crisis
it's clear what we need is greater
investment in clean and renewable energy
the environmental risks is outlined by
the motion of fracking are numerous
we know from cop26 and many other
sources that protect ourselves from
Runaway climate change the majority of
our fossil fuel reserves must remain in
the ground
fracking makes a mockery of this
imperative to reduce carbon emissions
plus it produces many other side effects
that are detrimental to our environment
can you wrap up now because we are going
to hit 9 30. I'm having the last word
yeah well no you're not because
councilor sorry I'm sorry Council
Council of Bot wishes to speak and I
need to allow councilman Jones to sum up
and we need to vote so please probably
15 seconds thank you I will wrap up I
apologize to councilor boss who's also
wanting to speak
let's reiterate our opposition to
fracking in Trafford by supporting this
motion as amended thank you mayor thank
you councilor Brophy Council of Bot
you've got less than a minute yes thank
you ma'am I'm just going to be very
short I just wanted to say that we've
historically uh opposed fracking in this
area uh and in in the in the region uh
and you know as things have been said
I personally do not feel that we need
the fracking uh in in this area and the
group will be as I say done what you
said right back to councilman Jones
anything to add at all no
um it sounds like we're all going to
vote to reaffirm our opposition to
fracking and hopefully that will be the
case thank you thank you Jones
um right I'm going to put now what is
effectively the amended motion uh agreed
by the labor party uh with without the
capital letters as the substantive vote
all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
the borough is still against fracking
right fine
the motion the amended motion the
substantive motion is carried thank you
that's the end of the meeting I thank
you for your attendance I hope you enjoy
the rest of your evening we're only
about two minutes ahead of time thank
you everybody if anyone wishes to join
me in the mayor's parlor for refreshment
please do so there's still wine there's
still soft drinks there's still beer and
do join me if you can thank you
foreign